white house standing by and defending
their dystopian disinformation board
after a huge uproar republicans say it
would lead to a big government crackdown
on free speech
biden's dhs secretary insisting this was
all some big understanding
there's no question brett that we could
have done a better job in communicating
what it does our work does not infringe
on free speech okay so it does not
infringe on civil rights civil liberties
it's not about
speech well it's about
the connectivity to violence
wow mayorkas also defended the hunter
biden laptop denying mary poppins
impersonator that they hired to run it
i don't question her objectivity there
are people in the department
who have a diverse range of views and
they're incredibly dedicated to mission
we're not the opinion
police she has testified before congress
a number of times she's recognized as a
tremendous authority and we're very
fortunate to have her
recognize this a tremendous authority
i'm going to let that one go but jessica
i want to bring this to you first you
know i mentioned it in my last uh answer
in the a block with short of six months
to the midterms right after elon musk
decides he's going to buy twitter right
when crime is going through the roof we
decide that we need or they decide they
need a disinformation board uh and it's
not really about freedom of speech
according to mayorkas it's about
connectivity what is he talking about do
you know i can only go with what he's
told us what did he tell us because i
can't figure it out he told us that
american citizens are not going to be
targeted that it's not about what we're
putting on social media which is
important and he acknowledged the fact
that they did a very poor job at rolling
this out and something that's been
brewing actually for months and it was
interesting allegedly
well in today's
press briefing jen saki answered peter
ducey about this and
okay well
i could just stop talking just let me
get through it and then you can say
allegedly but peter ducey asked about
this and jen saki said actually that
they were continuing work that started
under the trump administration which i
thought was very interesting but one
thing that
people don't do when they're in office
is they don't try to get in front of a
narrative based on what they know the
other side is going to say and it's
pretty easy to do just tune in to a
political commentator on the left and
the right and you will know the response
within 20 minutes of a news cycle
why didn't they do that you would know
exactly what people would say
why did this happen when elon musk took
over for twitter why is this woman on
tick tock is this a serious person is
this someone that deserves this kind of
job and then you could have given that
interview that he gave this weekend
in advance of this and we'd all be in a
lot of a better position so are you
saying that you you don't quite
understand it either
i said a lot more than that um i would
like more information about what it is
but i am relieved to hear that this is
not about targeting individual american
citizens for whatever they're putting
out there on social media that was the
big concern last week okay do you
believe that this has nothing to do with
free speech greg
um ministry i think it has to do with
competition they don't like their
freedom of speech to have any
competition they think i i believe that
they see
speech as a zero-sum game like if you
have if joey has more speech then that
means i don't know somebody at msnbc has
less speech that's the way they see it
that's why it's wrong this hysteria is
continuing because i think the legacy
media like cnn
know that it just
it's not too far off from being dead
they're i mean it didn't you know they
are so close they're watching their
numbers decline and every time there's a
threat they go crazy by the way it
didn't start with musk i would go back
and start it started with fox news when
fox news first came out they were
attacked and we still are attacked every
day then you i'd say you'd go after joe
rogan remember what's this like four
months ago it was all joe rogan joe
rogan joe rogan and then there was sub
stack all of these independent thinkers
leaving the democrats you know whether
it was matt tybee i don't know if they
were or glenn greenwald but they all go
to sub then they get attacked now it's
musk so every reaction you see is the
same they fear speech because it
competes with theirs by the way he's you
know york has ended that thing saying
like we're just looking at speech as it
connect yes it's connectivity to
violence
well let's not forget cnn was the one
that was defending antifa remember you
know anti-fog means anti-fascist and
like show me in the constitution where
it says you can't be whatever whatever
cuomo said uh but there are other during
the riots there were plenty of people on
the media that were defending that right
and saying it's a form of justice so i'd
be interested to see if they actually
will connect it to violence well you
know um one of the things dana that the
wall street journal talked about in
their editorial they said uh refereeing
political debate is not the government's
job
and that's again
they did a terrible job of explaining
what this is supposed to be like so it's
a board but who's on the board and who
created the board and who's going to pay
for the board because congress controls
the purse strings and so do you have the
actual authority to create this board
and when they say that americans are not
going to be targeted but how do you know
that the
fake information that you're trying to
dispel didn't come from somebody's
basement in colorado like well if that's
the case then of course you're going to
have to go after that information so
none of th they did a terrible job with
it plus they did a real disservice to
her jankowitz because these people are
supposed to be in charge of vetting
personnel it took one second for us to
find her videos on tick tock it's not
hard to understand her singing isn't
even the worst part it's her actual
beliefs yes yes and so they so now they
have basically put her in a position of
being dragged all the way through this
is
the people are work i actually think
that this is something that really
struck a chord with people um
a lot of other things maybe just kind of
blow by but this one is really sticking
uh the thing that they never answered is
this question what is the problem you're
trying to solve
just tell us what is the problem you're
trying to solve let's define it let's
look at it and let's make sure that
congress actually
has the authority you have the authority
from congress in order to do it because
that's how the system works i actually
think the sport is not going to exist
and she is not going to be in charge of
anything
but i think one of the issues joey is
the fact that um
that they haven't indicated what the
sanction is and if they give it a name
the disinformation board that tells me
that they're going to tell us when the
information is incorrect so what was
true yesterday may not be true tomorrow
for example with coving if you get the
vaccine you're not going to get coveted
or if you wear the mass you're going to
be protected but now they're saying you
don't even need to wear the mask you
know what's true today may not
necessarily be true tomorrow why are
they getting involved in this well he
said he said he said we're not the
opinion police no they're trying to be
the facts police that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to tell us
what is or isn't true and call it a fact
so that we don't question it
i'm really not all that appalled by this
and not to say that i appreciate it or
want it to exist but my opinion
they're just codifying what already
happens so now we have a face and a
voice and a name to put with it we know
who's doing it and who's behind it kind
of thing um you can't tell me that the
the the twitter suspension of the new
york post
didn't have back channel communication
if not this is the best form of of hive
mind that we've ever seen listen and you
know not to say
people are married to people that work
in the white house and work at different
media groups and work within people's
offices
these narratives circulate it just
happens to be that 80 percent of media
is involved in the one that the current
white house is involved in and so
they're going to back something like
this i think
really what it comes down to
is
now they're so worried about being able
to control a narrative or push narrative
out and they've been really ineffective
at it just as a white house this is just
the next step in that and maybe it gives
cover to the media outlets who are very
obviously up until now
carrying their water and now they're
starting to not carry their water so
much all right can i add something go
ahead uh the uh there is another
connection to the this board and elon
musk in the sense that when the when you
asked what was the board for well all of
this kind of stem from the idea of white
supremacy that there was this domestic
terror movement going on which they have
yet to figure out you find out you know
that fbi informants whatever
now you have the you have liberals
especially on msnbc meddy hassan saying
like you know free speech this what musk
is doing is
allowing for neo-nazism and white
supremacy so now
free speech is being redefined as some
kind of element of white supremacy
that's the connectivity they're going to
create a connectivity so now you are
trained in their narrative hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now